i've done a complete 180 on kanye west
this guy's a [ __ ] genius dude now i
know you guys started thinking he was
brilliant with the whole mag of stuff me
i was giving a lot of pushback i did you
you were like i think this guy's on to
something i did freedom right yeah make
america better i mean let's go
[Laughter]
so
um yeah that was it that was you know
that was you yeah and your constituents
you ted cruz and all your boys
all the people that you hang out with
all the [ __ ] times
right wing sing in the building
dude
that's really all that happens you put
out a funny comedy special and you just
become a right winger that's really
crazy dude right if your special is not
funny yeah the left likes you if it's
actually funny then the right's like
this guy's on to something
no problem for the left real talk this
guy's the horse yeah ben shapiro sees
like dave chappelle special about the
trans community he's like finally just
some funny stuff from this guy it's good
to see him being funny again right
that's literally what's happening yeah
if the right wing likes your stuff it's
probably funny yeah the jokes hold up if
they do i'm just saying if they want to
use you yeah right because i don't want
to be your puppet but i appreciate that
you appreciate my jokes exactly they
tend to like jokes the left tends to
like points exactly
that i think is the perfect way to say
it but just just to bring it back to
where you guys thought he was a genius
especially [ __ ] owl dude al
was out dude
wing out yeah
dude this is right wing out his beanie
gets smaller every episode
my head's getting bigger bro
why is it getting bigger
no al you
initially gave a i'll get i'll be fair
yeah you initially gave some pushback
yes to kanye when he went on that date
with the black one no no no no no
no it was when he was crying about
abortion i'm like what's the problem
he was often born
[Applause]
okay no um okay so so kanye right
this week
he just starts deciding to
to bully pete davidson i mean it's so
unnecessary so like literally just
trying to roast them
right and i'm i'm sitting here i'm going
like what the [ __ ] did pete do yeah like
what did he do wrong
i'm literally going what did he do wrong
nothing bro wait what did he do wrong
he's been plotting oh oh you think
that's all yeah he's been playing on
camera if that's the case then i
understand and bullying him yeah okay go
on that go on that i mean like he's been
throwing like shade at kanye for a
minute on snl all the time
like he's done that three times on snl
like throw like just a little shade at
kanye well it's not even that many for
kanye like think about how much kanye
opens himself up to be made fun of and
he took three shots but he's still
homies kind of like he's cool with cuddy
and cuddy's cool with yay they should be
a little bit like yo don't take shots at
me on a [ __ ] national television
i guess and then come on my wife yeah
okay yeah that's always taking shots in
he's taking shots
the breakup fire come on that's [ __ ]
up [ __ ] while he's there son he's an
actor he's in the audience
you don't think connie's a [ __ ] you
don't think he just rolled his [ __ ]
heads whatever that thing is
[Music]
[Laughter]
his head
what does that mean
dude i almost got a head scarf
um
no no the reason why i called him genius
i thought it was it was mean that he's
bullying pete but i'm also like pete
you're a comedian like now that this is
your wheelhouse yeah bodybuilding
yeah like if he wants to get into it
with music with you
just bow out gracefully yes but if his
jokes
body are these [ __ ] walking
around with cowboy boots on all day
yeah come on bro now it's time yeah now
it's time to start shooting that being
said the genius of kanye is this
i don't think
kanye gives a flying [ __ ] about pete
i don't think he cares about anybody
sleeping with him
i think kanye only cares about kanye
i okay okay
i think what kanye does is when it's
time to drop an album or if he's you
know going through an episode and i
don't want to chalk up all his behavior
to like a mental episode i think that's
kind of unfair you're like just to
discredit any behavior that we have or
he has that we don't like as like oh
it's a mental episode whatever but i
think what he does is
when kanye's in the i want attention
mode
whatever generates attention he latches
on to and continues to pull
into his universe right he went on a
date with a few girls before julia fox
that julia fox date blew up on the
internet and i think he was like oh this
is my girlfriend now yes i don't know if
it's oh my god i have so much in common
julia fox i love julia fox i think it's
simple the internet loves what's going
on over here let's milk this for a
little bit yes see how long this is
interesting for right he goes at pete
the internet [ __ ] explodes
oh i'm going to keep going to pete
i'm going to keep going to pete over and
over and over again i'm going to post
memes i'm going to post more jokes so
i'm going to call them ugly do all these
things i don't think he gives a flying
[ __ ] that there's somebody with kim if
he cared that people slept with his wife
he wouldn't have wifed her kim she has a
sex tape out literally who didn't [ __ ]
her i think he likes the people [ __ ]
i think he likes it i think he likes it
dude because he's a [ __ ] okay
dude i think he's a cop
allegedly i i can't be calling people
he's a right-wing [ __ ] dude why is he
wrong he's a right-winger
yes
because usually closet cuck's our right
wing i don't think he's even closeted i
think he likes open cook i think he's
open
out of the closet [ __ ] dude all right
out of the closet right wing [ __ ] okay
100 percent
so
actually i'm not 100 sure about this
again this is your right wing this is
your theory genius cuck as well i think
he's a right-wing genius cop dude
low-key that's the next level right
honestly
right-wing [ __ ] are better dude why is
this
it just seems to be like yeah [ __ ] her
do you know what i mean like
like like it feels like like a liberal
like a liberal [ __ ] would be in the
corner like don't [ __ ] my life
but right-wing would be like oh that's
all you got no she doesn't like that
yeah do it differently yeah yeah yeah
you can't fill that up yeah jesus yeah
you can't trench her oh he's a he's a
coach he's a coat but he's telling her
what to do alpha yeah like he's making
beats bro yeah
this guy
right he's a creative yeah he's gonna
make a movie out of this experience that
is kind of right-wing mentality like you
just wanna like outsource your labor
like let someone else do it i'm gonna go
work on forex trading or some [ __ ] yes
it's kind of 100 you can't do everything
do you think elon's actually building
the rockets he's a rocket [ __ ] dude yeah
someone else is building his [ __ ]
rockets yes he's building his car [ __ ]
dude steve jobs
he's a he's an iphone music listening
[ __ ] he's the biggest he's the biggest
kick in history steve jobs do you think
yeah dude do you think we just outsource
it to everybody else namely chinese
slaves just tech cup can't we just call
them chinese at this point
if they're working and making things
we know that they're slaves over there
right yeah it's true or very minimal
wage
yeah very minimal slave wage you might
slave waged you might even say might
even it's a goddamn shame all i'm trying
to say is kanye
is a genius with his ability to
recognize what is going on continue to
stir up the [ __ ] pot what is the
expression charlemagne always says stir
up water so you can catch fish
that is that is it is genius what he's
doing he's just watching it week after
week another thing oh people really care
that i'm beefing with pete davidson i'm
a lean all the way in with this people
davidson [ __ ] he gets it dude all he
wants is attention yep he is a vacuum
for it
and uh maybe he's doing it because
there's an album roll out maybe he's
doing it because
he's sad you know maybe he's doing
because he's having a mental episode but
it's undeniable his ability to get
everybody
in at least the united states talking
about it is there a chance all three of
them are okay with everything
i've thought about that go on that like
if i'm if i'm kim my entire career has
been drama the entire show and they got
a new streaming deal is oh there's so
much craziness happening in my life why
don't you watch it unfold yeah on the
show yup so she got no problem with this
yup if you're pete
think about your level of fame when
kanye starts attacking you online
if even if he's not like privy to it all
and knows about it in advance i bet he's
cool with it
kanye west is jealous of me
think about the [ __ ] level that puts
you on an snl credit not supposed to get
you this yeah this must give you a
couple movies that people probably don't
see what was the last breakout star
before pete on snl sudeikis kristen wiig
that's 10 plus years ago he got an snl
credit and now he's being mentioned dude
eddie murphy is the last guy i remember
being mentioned like this from snl yo
this is so true and is it
true gender equality
cause pete has slept his way to the top
yes like we hear
all the time that women sleeping their
way to the top i don't know what women
slept their way to the top i know women
have slept their way to like the middle
or the upper
top but one woman really slept her way
to the top and this [ __ ] nancy
reagan yeah
is peter nancy reagan
of whatever we're talking about
what are we talking about your way to
the top celebrities
sleeping your way to the top yes yes yes
is he the nancy reagan a [ __ ] yes
unbelievable
and she
[Music]
was the first lady she got to give tours
to the white house and [ __ ] pete don't
even got to give tours of kanye's old
crib
we've seen it
right we've seen it we know it doesn't
have a hot tub yeah
it doesn't have a hot tub yeah that was
the first crack in the foundation of
their marriage bam that [ __ ] is the
funniest video you obviously that one
where kim goes like uh kevin goes yeah
and you know we don't even have a hot
tub and then
can you believe it can you believe it we
don't even have a hunt
that's when i was like oh it's starting
to crack right here yeah it's over it's
over
[Applause]